ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants est ce que le petit
chien perdu à retrouver son maître ou sa
maman chez eux nous allons voir ça pas
trop ma petite échelle
aux bobos
teyssot gay tony regarde
il est terrible as tu tombe bien du fond
c'est lui j -pd ou les déchirent tout
regarde ma chaussette mais c'est pour
jouer les petits chiens adore s'amuser
l'on sait lui une balle vous allez voir
et voilà il court après
[Musique]
ne mord pas les pattes je suis pas le
bal
attend que pas chercher
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
que le coca attrape la balle ne parut
pas
à tout coup je t'attrape quoi
encore nous voir je t'aurais petits
microbes
[Musique]
génie
je te tiens
peux-tu trop
[Musique]
aux mondiaux il a sommé tu allais main
fait courir c'est plutôt lui qui m'a
fait courir je crois qu'il est temps
qu'il retrouve sa famille
cette grève
est soit sage garn mots
mais non nous en échange c'est vrai
bonne nuit les petits
atomes
annonce
nicolas temps bien peter
[Musique]
alors nounours tout va bien à peu près
pas trop mais j'aimerais bien que ce
petit chien retrouve sa maman pourquoi
il est un peu capricieux et pas très
respectueux avec nous mon pauvre
nounours allons en route oui route va
nuit les enfants pub
m
[Musique]